et notre invité politique ce matin
c'était bonjour bonjour merci d'être
avec nous ministre de la transformation
et de la fonction publique on est
ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour une
interview en partenariat avec la presse
régionale représentée par Stéphane
Vernet de westfrance bonjour Stéphane
bonjour bonjour à vous on va parler de
la réforme des retraites pour commencer
cette Grigny c'est donc vendredi que le
Conseil constitutionnel doit rendre sa
décision sur ce texte est-ce que vous la
redoutez cette décision non je pense que
dans une démocratie chacun doit attendre
ce type de décision sereinement sans
commencer comme je l'entends parfois par
remettre en cause par anticipation ce
que dira le Conseil constitutionnel
c'est quand même un peu la petite
musique à la mode en ce moment de
décrédibiliser par anticipation de dire
à ce qui serait légitime parce que telle
ou telle personnalité ou un jour était
ici ou là moi je ne jouerai pas à ce jeu
là je crois que personne au gouvernement
et que l'ensemble du gouvernement
attendra respectueusement respectera
l'édition du Conseil constitutionnel
tout simplement c'est je crois ce qui
convient de faire dans une démocratie
mais vous redoutez que certaines
oppositions de la respectent pas cette
décision non je commente ce que
j'entends à l'instant T et moi je crois
qu'il faut être séquentiel il faut
passer des haies les unes après les
autres faut pas chercher à mettre les
wagons dans le mauvais sens donc
attendons ce que va dire le Conseil
constitutionnel le pays doit pas
s'arrêter à la décision du Conseil
constitutionnel il y a beaucoup de
choses qui avancent qui continue
d'avancer cette réforme des retraites et
une réforme on l'a dit qui est
indispensable qui n'est certes pas
populaire mais qui est indispensable
aussi pour pouvoir avancer financer
notre modèle social financer notre
modèle de retraite par répartition je
crois que on doit continuer à
s'intéresser à tous les sujets et il y
en a de nombreux il y a beaucoup de
choses à faire dans le pays donc tout ne
doit pas s'arrêter la décision du
Conseil constitutionnelle quelle qu'elle
soit permettra tel vraiment d'avancer
c'est-à-dire de tourner la page de cette
réforme dans un sens ou dans un autre à
votre sens il le faut c'est tout l'objet
de ce que nous faisons pour essayer de
reprendre aussi le dialogue avec des
organisations syndicales le fil à jamais
été complètement coupé je l'entends
aussi parfois on continue d'échanger
d'avancer il faut voir sur quel sujet on
peut le faire pour pouvoir aussi
redémarrer ce dialogue là qui est
indispensable vous savez moi quand je
vais rencontrer des agents publics on
parle parfois des retraites c'est vrai
mais on parle de beaucoup d'autres
sujets on parle de pouvoir d'achat on
parle de conditions de travail de
pénibilité de la façon dont on peut
construire une carrière dans la fonction
publique par exemple ce sont des sujets
qui sont d'intérêt pour les agents et je
crois que les syndicats sont conscients
il a vraiment repris le dire aussi
redémarrer ce dialogue il y a vraiment
reprises vous étiez à Matignon avec
Elizabeth borne le jour de la rencontre
avec les syndicats n'a pas été
formidablement réussi cette cette
rencontre est-ce qu'il y a est-ce qu'il
y a vraiment dialogue quand personne ne
s'écoute comme nous sommes rencontrés la
semaine dernière c'était important qu'on
puisse tout simplement s'écouter
dialoguer ça a vraiment été le cas oui
ça a été le cas vraiment dans un échange
qui a été respectueux il faut pas
oublier que nous étions dans un moment
où parfois se manifester des formes de
violence pas du tout celle des
manifestants encadrés par les
syndicalistes au contraire la première
ministre a reconnu cette capacité des
syndicats justement à mener une
opposition forte dans la rue mais
respectueuse de la démocratie moi je
crois que ces moments-là ils ont aussi
de la valeur tout simplement parfois
pour ça pour montrer que en
responsabilité des acteurs peuvent se
parler certains sujets ont été évoqués
ceux que j'ai évoqué à l'instant la
nature du travail la construction des
carrières celle du pouvoir d'achat mais
vous avez parlé d'autres choses que de
la réforme des retraites oui mais en
transparence la première ministre a
elle-même reconnue qu'on n'avait pas pu
approfondir ces sujets là les syndicats
ont dit des choses importantes certains
d'entre eux ont dit on se retrouvera
pour parler de ce sujet quoi qu'il
arrive sur la réforme des retraites mais
pas maintenant parce que nous avons une
opposition fondamentale sur le recul de
l'âge alors effectivement la réunion a
pas servi à permettre de régler ce
désaccord là et je pense que personne ne
s'attendait à ce que on se mette
d'accord sur le fait de reculer l'âge
des retraites dans cette réunion
dans un moment où se manifeste un
symptôme de tension et de violence dans
le pays que des acteurs en
responsabilité gouvernement et syndicats
puissent se parler ça a de la valeur ça
a de la valeur aussi pour parler de nos
accords et nos désaccords prendra acte
aussi qu'on doit continuer à avancer à
faire avancer un certain temps de sujet
qui est encore une fois soit apte
absolument essentiels à la fois pour
l'avenir du pays mais pour le quotidien
aussi des salariés des agents publics et
je crois que cette réunion elle a servi
à ça c'est une étape et ça n'était pas
plus qu'une étape mais il y a des
syndicats qui sont prêts à discuter
d'autres sujets même si vous ne retirez
pas votre réforme des retraites oui bien
que nous sommes là dans un moment où
effectivement
dans l'attente de la décision du Conseil
constitutionnel vous le disiez vous-même
les regards sont encore davantage
tournés sur la réforme des retraites
c'est l'évidence et moi j'ai jamais
considéré que c'était à nous de dire
quand les gens avaient le droit d'être
en colère ou plus le droit d'être en
colère vous voyez c'est un moment où
nous sommes encore dans une séquence
autour des retraites en ce qui concerne
les organisations syndicales elles
cherchent à mobiliser une journée de
mobilisation jeudi et donc elle voulait
pas passer à autre chose évidemment mais
tout ça est dans une démocratie un
dialogue qui me semble plutôt normal on
devra effectivement retrouver ce chemin
là pour pouvoir avancer et oui je crois
que il y a des possibilités de pouvoir
le faire avec des organisations
syndicales avec l'ensemble des
partenaires sociaux pour l'intérêt des
salariés pour l'intérêt des Français
tout simplement pour intérêt des agents
publics par France que me concerne mais
vous pensez que le dialogue pourra
reprendre normalement avec les syndicats
ou cette réforme des retraites elle a de
toute façon laissé des traces dans le
dialogue social il le faut c'est
l'intérêt du pays que l'on puisse
avancer sur ces sujets là donc encore
une fois ne mettons pas les wagons dans
le mauvais sens écoutons ce que dira le
Conseil constitutionnel vendredi on
verra s'il valide entièrement la loi
s'il la valide partiellement tout ça
nécessitera totalement un dialoguer il y
a beaucoup de sujets vous savez qui sont
dans la réforme des retraites et qui
sont totalement liées au sujet que nous
discutons sur les parcours de carrière
la pénibilité etc nous avons décidé pour
la fonction publique d'introduire la
retraite progressive c'est-à-dire la
capacité à se mettre à temps partiel en
gardant sa rémunération c'est pas une
petite affaire ça ça peut concerner
beaucoup d'agents publics les syndicats
regardent avec intérêts ce type de
mesure là il y a beaucoup de mesures sur
notamment la portabilité des droits pour
des agents qui sont catégoriques pour
qu'ils puissent mieux changer de métier
demain nous avons décidé de créer un
fond d'usure 100 millions d'euros par an
à 2000 milliards d'euros sur le
quinquennat sont pas des petits sujets
ça qu'est-ce qu'on fait de ça donc vous
voyez tous ces sujets là il nécess de se
remettre à table de discuter de voir
qu'est-ce qu'on en fait parce qu'on a
beaucoup à faire il faut passer d'une
logique de réparation celle qui consiste
à partir un peu plus tôt à la retraite
parce qu'on a un métier pénible à
davantage une logique de prévention
professionnelle c'est une révolution que
nous devons mener ensemble les culturesl
et les managersales elle est dans
l'organisation du travail ce sont des
dans l'autre sens Stanislas Guerrini
commencez par s'occuper de la question
de travail et après de la question des
retraites de temps en temps j'entends ça
comme si nous n'avions rien fait sur la
question de travail c'est évidemment un
correspond pas à la réalité sur la
formation professionnelle sur la
revalorisation de l'apprentissage des
métiers aussi manuels beaucoup a déjà
été fait et donc on doit mais poursuivre
il y a une loi travail
beaucoup restent à faire mais mettons
les mois qui sont devant nous vous savez
la réforme des retraites elle a vocation
à s'appliquer à partir de septembre
après le mois d'été bien mettons ce
temps à profit pour qu'il soit un temps
utile pour pouvoir travailler aux
questions de travail il y a
effectivement une loi travail qui est en
cours de préparation moi-même je mène
des chanter sur la fonction publique sur
les rémunérations les parcours de
carrière l'accès à la fonction publique
les conditions de travail des questions
essentielles comment est-ce que on loge
davantage de fonctionnaires comment
est-ce qu'on module mieux son temps de
travail comment on aménage les espaces
de travail dans un monde où le
télétravail se développe comment on
renforce la culture managériale dans la
fonction publique tout ça ce sont des
questions qui sont absolument
essentielles et que moi je souhaite
traiter là dans les semaines qui sont
devant nous c'est tout le sens de la
sociale que j'ai construite des
organisations syndicales alors
aujourd'hui elle nous disent là on est
dans le temps des retraites
laissez-nous respirer on n'a pas envie
de parler de ces sujets là mais il faut
bien redémarrer on doit faire face à une
inflation qui est importante il y a des
questions qui sont posées les syndicats
me disent est-ce que vous allez faire
sur le point d'indice sur la
rémunération ce sont des agents donc je
me sens aussi de l'appétence à pouvoir
discuter ces sujets là moi c'est avec
eux que j'ai envie de discuter de ces
sujets on m'interroge parfois sur les
plateaux de télévision en ce moment
qu'est-ce que vous allez faire d'un
point de vue salarial pour les agents
publics en ce moment moi je réponds que
c'est d'abord avec les organisations
syndicales que je veux discuter de ces
questions-là je constate bien je
constate que les inflation qui est
importante au global en train de
décélérer mais qui est particulièrement
accentué sur les produits de première
nécessité qui est particulièrement
accentué sur l'alimentaire où on voit
encore des pourcentages à deux chiffres
et donc je crois que ceux qui sont les
plus impactés par cette inflation là ce
sont plutôt les bas salaires les entrées
de grille dans la fonction publique
alors ça c'est une discussion qu'on doit
avoir comment est-ce qu'on concentre nos
efforts peut-être pour mieux accompagner
ceux qui sont en entrée de grille qui
viennent prendre deux plein fouet
l'impact de l'inflation générale en tout
cas elles sont sur la table mais ce sera
on doit aller discuter avec les
organismes ou la revalorisation générale
du point d'indice est ouverte non plus
on n'est pas au bout du chemin de la
discussion qu'on doit mener je pose un
constat celui que je fais devant vous ce
matin et tout ça nécessite discussion
concertation peut-être négociation avec
tes organisations à syndicales
le plus rapidement possible mais là
encore j'entends oui ça serait mon
intention mais j'entends de la part de
nos partenaires des partenaires sociaux
aussi une forme de respect du rythme il
y a là un moment qui est sur les
retraites il y a eu un temps de dialogue
social moi j'insiste et j'en reparle
souvent parce que c'est un temps qui a
permis de mettre des mesures pas de
dépasser des accords sur l'âge mais de
mettre des mesures intéressantes dans le
texte on est cité quelques-unes ce matin
il y a eu un temps de débat
parlementaire il fallait aussi le
respecter il y a un temps maintenant qui
est plutôt constitutionnel avec une
décision sur la nature même du texte et
puis il faudra ensuite avancer
en disant il ne faut pas que les
syndicats sortent humiliés de cette
séquence et que comment on fait pour que
les syndicats ne soient pas humiliés de
cette séquence vous voyez d'abord la
recette je dis ce matin saluer leur
responsabilité dans ce moment qui a été
un moment de conflit social qui continue
puisqu'il y a encore des mobilisations
qui sont qui sont prévues et qui a été
fait dans une grande responsabilité de
pouvoir distinguer les acteurs tout le
monde n'a pas été aussi responsable dans
le débat public ça c'est peut-être la
première étape du dialogue la deuxième
c'est d'être ouvert à pouvoir continuer
à discuter à dialoguer c'était le sens
de l'invitation de la première ministre
la troisième condition à mon sens c'est
aussi de respecter la temporalité que
souhaite les organisations syndicales
leur dire sur quel sujet ce qu'on se
remet autour de la table on souhaite pas
alors imposer tout un agenda
repartons les sujets d'intérêt qui sont
manifestés par les organisations
vendredi tout ça bout à bout je vous dis
ça parce que moi je crois peu vous voyez
à la grand-messe qui met tout le monde
autour de la table sur un calendrier un
agenda qui aurait été ça veut dire
qu'une partie des syndicats si vendredi
le Conseil constitutionnel ne censure
pas le texte et que le principe du
départ de l'âge de départ à la retraite
et bien validé à 64 ans vous avez
certains syndicats qui ne voudront pas
reprendre les négociations je pense
notamment à la CGT mais peut-être
d'autres comment vous faites pour
renouer le dialogue social si vous
restez dans une position de blocage moi
je crois qu'il faut toujours repartir de
l'intérêt des Français de l'intérêt des
gens reprenez avec uniquement une partie
des partenaires sociaux pas tous mais
vous voyez il faut partir de là où il y
a de la demande de discussion les
questions que nous sommes en train de
discuter depuis ce matin je pense que
personne ne comptait ce qu'elles sont
absolument essentielles et que en ce qui
me concerne les agents publics en ce qui
concerne d'autres ministres les salariés
également demande qu'on puisse discuter
de ces questions demande qu'on puisse
avancer je crois que c'est ça la vie
politique aussi de faire en partant de
l'intérêt le plus profond du pays c'est
ça qui donne du poids à la capacité à
pouvoir discuter mais tout ça
respectueuse c'est aussi est-ce qu'il y
a besoin d'un autre geste pour un
calendrier est-ce qu'il y a besoin
d'autres gestes politiques de de
matérialiser cette ouverture ou cette
volonté de se rapprocher et de passer à
autre chose est-ce que ça peut être
matérialisé autrement mais partir des
sujets d'intérêt ce que veulent discuter
les organisations syndicales et les
agents c'est déjà un geste d'ouverture
après moi je veux pas faire de politique
fiction on est souvent amené à commenter
par anticipation ce que ont été les
décisions du Conseil constitutionnel par
exemple quand on parle de la réforme des
retraites je pense qu'il faut concernant
la réforme des retraites être pardon un
peu patient sage cette semaine c'est
peut-être le mot qui convient et puis
ensuite en tirer le plus collectivement
possible
il y a pas d'autres intentions de la
part du gouvernement les conséquences
avec nos partenaires les plus naturels
que sont les partenaires sociaux quand
Elisabeth Bank dit qu'il faut pas que
les syndicats sortent humiliés qu'il
faut respecter une période de
convalescence qu'il faut l'apaisement
c'est quand même une remise en question
de la méthode d'Emmanuel Macron non
vraiment sincèrement je pense pas j'ai
vu là aussi à chercher à opposer ce que
serait la ligne de la première ministre
et la ligne du président de la
République c'est la même ligne la
volonté de faire avancer notre pays à
tant qu'à faire encore sur le sujet
aussi
que la question du travail que celle des
services publics les deux ont cette même
volonté de faire avancer notre pays mais
c'est le rôle de la première ministre
que d'être en première ligne du dialogue
social aussi avec des organisations
la fonction publique et donc c'est son
rôle de de nouer ce dialogue là c'est ça
aussi nos institutions se respectent là
donc il y a pas de ligne différentes il
y a une seule volonté celle de faire
avancer le pays il y a une première
ministre qui large du mission difficile
qui est aussi celle de dialoguer de
trouver les voies et moyens justement
pour pouvoir avancer Emmanuel Macron ne
va pas trop loin avec la cfdts qu'il
n'est pas trop critique avec la CFDT on
sent que ça exaspère un peu Laurent
Berger
président de la République à distance
moi je
considère que le Président de la
République c'est toujours
que la CFDT
propositions respectueux des
institutions présents de la République
a dit aux Français à la télévision ce
qu'il avait à leur dire pour pouvoir
justement faire redémarrer notre pays et
avancer le reste ce sont des
commentaires
sur les Français parce que les Français
ils contestent la réforme des retraites
mais il y a aussi d'autres sujets
d'inquiétudes notamment la disparition
des services publics comment vous
répondez à ça justement en
réinvestissant sur nos territoires sur
nos services publics voyez on ouvre
aujourd'hui encore des maisons France
pour ramener des services publics du
quotidien sur nos territoires en
réinvestissant dans l'école pour qu'on
puisse mieux rémunérer nos professeurs
en réinvestissant dans l'hôpital qui a
tant de difficultés aujourd'hui j'étais
encore à tour la semaine dernière dans
un hôpital pour justement avec les
agents travailler à ces questions qui
sont des questions capitales ça c'est ce
qui intéresse au quotidien moi je suis
parfois frappé la différence des
discussions qui peut avoir sur les
plateaux de télévision plutôt parisien
et ce qu'on peut trouver comme réalité
sur le terrain et surtout comme attente
beaucoup plus dépassionné par rapport
aux grands débat où il y a beaucoup de
positions il y a de la convergence qui
peut se faire justement sur le terrain
moi je crois à ça que en faisant pas pas
ce que les Français attendent de nous
c'est-à-dire remettre des services
publics au quotidien c'est comme ça
aussi qu'on peut faire avancer notre
pays les questions que vous posez sur
les services publics je crois qu'elles
sont absolument fondamentales et
qu'elles doivent nourrir aussi l'agenda
politique pour l'après retraite d'une
certaine façon on doit s'intéresser de
nouvelles mesures bah au grand service
public l'école la santé la justice les
attentes sont importantes mais on doit
aussi davantage peut-être encore
s'intéresser aux fondamentaux des
services publics ce qui fait le
quotidien de nos concitoyens cette
démarche administrative qui est pas
facile à régler ce téléphone il y a
personne qui décroche derrière moi c'est
ça le boulot qui à mon avis doit être
une nouvelle de nouvelles mesures pour
simplifier les démarches pour faciliter
le quotidien des Français simplifier en
partant de la vie des gens là encore on
a beaucoup fait de simplification pour
la simplification au fond en partant de
nos contraintes à nous administration et
en essayant de simplifier les choses
résultat parfois on rajoute même des
couches de complexité avec beaucoup de
bonnes intentions initiales ben moi je
crois qu'il faut plutôt partir de la vie
des français de la naissance jusqu'au
décès au grand moment où on a des
démarches administratives et il y aura
des nouvelles mesures essayez de les
régler davantage faire en sorte que le
gouvernement a pied d'oeuvre sur ce
sujet là on développe les papiers
d'identité plus rapidement c'est un
sujet de forte mobilisation avec ma
collègue Dominique Faure avec Gérald
Darmanin mobilisant tous les réseaux en
travaillant aussi avec les collectivités
parce que ces réponses là on doit les
faire dans une articulation très fine
les gens n'ont rien à faire de savoir si
c'est les tasses c'est la région c'est
le département c'est la commune ils
veulent qu'on leur règle leur problème
donc ça ça va concentrer toute notre
attention mais notamment sur ces grands
chantiers ces grands moments de vie je
mobilise avec mes collègues du
gouvernement l'ensemble de la machine
justement pour régler ces questions là
clé dans les moments de vie qui
constituent au fond les points de
rencontre avec les Français entre les
Français leur administration dans ces
points de rencontre donc quand vous
parlez de rencontres c'est vraiment de
rencontre physique qui rencontre de
terrain de proximité je vous pose la
question parce qu'il y a beaucoup de
démarches qui peuvent être faites en
ligne on sait aujourd'hui qu'il y a un
Français sur trois
d'achats qui est éloigné du numérique ce
qu'on appelait ce qu'on appelle parfois
l'électronisme fait 16 millions de
personnes qui sont qui sont qui
éprouvent des difficultés vis-à-vis de
ces démarches qu’est-ce que vous faites
pour eux mais même aller un peu plus
loin de vous au-delà des 16 millions de
personnes qui sont directement touchées
et du mauvais côté de la barrière d'un
point de vue de la fracture numérique
vous et moi beaucoup de personnes ont
rencontré un moment donné une difficulté
avec le numérique parce que la démarche
fonctionne mal parce qu'on a besoin d'un
coup de main tout simplement et là on a
besoin d'une alternative moi je crois
que l'erreur
ça serait d'arrêter le numérique le dire
avec tout ça fonctionne pas au fond et
l'alternative
d'interaction 2 milliards d'interactions
tous les ans entre les Français et une
administration plus de 90% de ces
interactions se font via le numérique
donc évidemment faut pas arrêter il faut
faire du bon numérique d'abord faut
commencer par ça du bon numérique c'est
du numérique ou par exemple on vous
demande pas 10 fois la même information
en fonction de l'administration que vous
avez devant vous s'appelle le dites le
nous une fois et donc ça veut dire qu'il
faut que les administrations partagent
leurs données ça c'est le cœur de ma
tâche du bon numérique c'est du
numérique inclusif accessible aux
personnes qui sont en situation de
handicap parfois quand on a un problème
de déficience visuelle on se retrouve
justement contre son gré du mauvais côté
de la barrière donc d'abord du bon
numérique et puis ensuite toujours
penser à avoir une alternative tout
simplement réinvestir dans l'humain
parce que les gens ce qu'ils veulent
c'est d'avoir des voix et des visages
d'un langui derrière un numéro de
téléphone c'est pour ça qu'on ouvre des
agences France service 2600 aujourd'hui
150 de plus sur l'année qui vient on
réinvesti par dizaines de millions
d'euros pour enrichir les services qu'on
va pouvoir aller mener pour développer
aussi l'allée vera on a su le faire
pendant un vaccination développer des
bus et la 135 aujourd'hui des bus
mobiles pour amener les services publics
mettre des gens des spécialistes du
numérique aussi sur le terrain on a créé
les conseillers numériques France
service 4000 personnes qui sont
déployées sur le terrain pour aller à la
rencontre former les Français parfois
ouvrir une adresse email vous voyez
c'est ça cette politique vous pouvez me
rendre débat qu'on peut avoir moi je
crois que c'est fondamentaux des
services publics c'est une clé pour
aussi retrouver la confiance des
Français
un nombre de démission jamais atteints
au niveau des élus locaux sur ce qui se
passe dans nos mairies également la
semaine dernière le Sénat a voté un
texte pour revaloriser le statut des
secrétaires de mairie mais les sénateurs
disent aussi la balle est dans le camp
du gouvernement qu'est-ce que vous allez
faire bien sûr et dans le corps de tous
les employeurs publics employeur
territoriaux comme le gouvernement et
donc moi j'ai soutenu les mesures de bon
sens qui était
issues de cette proposition de loi des
sénateurs faut s'intéresser aux
compétences au recrutement et au
parcours de carrières et de rémunération
je veux faire les secrétaires de mairie
un bon exemple de justement notre
capacité à faire bouger les lignes c'est
vrai les secrétaires de mairie il y en a
un tiers qui vont partir à la retraite
dans les 8 prochaines années à chaque
fois qu'on arrive pas à remplacer une
secrétaire mairie on perd des services
publics c'est comme si on fermait une
maison française c'est-à-dire pour tirer
le fil de ce que je disais et donc oui
c'est vrai mais parce que c'est une
correction qui est très est-ce que vous
allez prendre des mesures pour
revaloriser le statut je veux qu'on
puisse effectivement recruter plus
facilement élargir les filières de
recrutement aujourd'hui les secrétaire
de mairesse sont recrutés dans les
filières administratives simplement il
faut qu'on puisse recruter un plus grand
nombre d'agents mettre le paquet sur la
formation formation initiale formation
de professionnalisation ça ça se
travaille avec justement les acteurs
avec le CNFPT avec les collectivités et
puis travailler un parcours de carrière
et de rémunération qui soit mieux
adaptée au secrétaire de mairie là aussi
qui ont été faites dans le dernier
quinquennat ils ont eu pardon pour les
termes techniques mais ça parlera
secrétaire de mairie NBI de 15 points
c'est environ 70-80 euros de plus par
mois est-ce que c'est suffisant
certainement pas il y aura d'autres
mesures sont quand on doit construire
ces solutions là avec les collectivités
moi j'ai pris un engagement mutualiser
aussi
l'été et de donner les traductions
concrètes dans le projet de loi de
finances parce que les employeurs ce
sont des employeurs territoriaux oui la
question que vous me posez sur la
nationalisation bien sûr qu'elle est sur
la table aujourd'hui on voit que les
secrétaires de mairie une des
difficultés c'est que leur temps est
partagée entre une deux trois temps
partiel à chaque collectivité elles ont
quatre employeurs en face d'elle c'est
compliqué pour elle c'est compliqué
d'ailleurs pour les collectivités aussi
donc moi je crois que les centres de
gestion les interco peuvent plus
facilement recruter des secrétaires de
mairie et ensuite
mettre leur temps à disposition d'un
point de vue partagé peut-être ça
offrira des possibilités supplémentaires
aussi en termes de rémunération un
dernier mot puisque vous avez dirigé le
parti présidentiel il y aura une
convention de renaissance samedi sur la
question de la fin de vie est-ce que
c'est un sujet qui divise Renaissance
est-ce que vous vous êtes favorable à la
mise en place d'une aide active à
Montréal moi je me prononce à titre
absolument personnel je suis favorable à
ce qu'on puisse avancer et donner plus
de possibilités de décider mais je le
dis à titre personnel parce que
justement le travail qui a été fait par
la Convention Stanley citoyenne pardon
est un travail absolument remarquable
qui permet de démêler des sujets qui
permet de préparer aussi un consensus et
donc je crois qu'il faut être très
respectueux du travail qui a été fait
l'euthanasie personnelle vous êtes pour
la légalisation de l'euthanasie à titre
personnel favorable à ce qu'on facilite
sa capacité à choisir sa fin de vie mais
cette question elle doit être prise avec
beaucoup de respect dans un travail très
minutieux respectueux
là encore de ce qui a été fait par ces
184 citoyens qui ont permis de faire
émerger des points de consensus fort qui
ont respecté aussi les dissensus qui
pouvaient y avoir et qui préparent je
crois formidablement bien le travail
législatif qui maintenant s'ouvre sans
opposer la démocratie participative et
la démocratie représentative je crois
que on a pris cette convention non très
sincèrement je pense pas que ce sera un
sujet de division mais au contraire à
ceux qui doit amener maintenant les
acteurs politiques à mener ce travail
pour construire la loi merci
beaucoup d'avoir été notre invité la Une
de Ouest-France le boum des livreurs à
vélo toujours plus précaires c'est à la
Une de votre journal Stéphane merci
beaucoup